-Andy, nobody knows
the "Real Housewives" franchise
like you.
The name of the book is
"It's Not All
Diamonds and Rosé"?
-Correct.
-There you go.
Preorder right now.
But look, there's a very --
There's a lot of iconic lines
out there on these shows,
and we want to put you
to the test.
This is a game called
"Who Said It?"
Here we go.
-♪ Tell 'em who said it ♪
♪ Tell 'em who said it, yeah ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, here's how it works.
I'm going to read you
real quotes
from any "Real Housewives"
show, any one.
-Okay.
-And you have to tell me
who said it.
-Okay.
Is there a prize?
-Uh...
[ Laughter ]
Pride.
-Pride.
-Pride, yeah.
-Yeah, I will say,
if I mess this game up,
I will do a major walk of shame
home to my place.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. It'd be terrible.
-Almost like me
when I went on your show
and you did this
with Grateful Dead songs.
-And you aced it.
-I was pressured.
-Yes, yes.
-Thank you. I appreciate it.
-Okay.
-All right, ready?
The first quote is...
-Yes.
That was said by
Mary M. Cosby
from "The Real Housewives
of Salt Lake City."
Sunday nights on Bravo.
-Let's see who said it.
Let's see who said it.
-And I said, "You smell
like hospital."
[ Ding ]
-[ Laughs ] That is correct.
That is correct!
[ Applause ]
All right, one for one.
All right, quote...
-"Who is Hunky Dory?"
Said Kathy Hilton on "The Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills."
-Let's show it.
-Just sit there and pretend like
everything is great
and hunky dory when it's not.
-Who is Hunky Dory?
[ Ding ]
♪♪
-It's so good.
-"Who is Hunky Dory?"
Kathy Hilton.
-It's so good.
How dare anyone think
this show is scripted?
-No, exactly.
-What writer's room could
come up with this brilliance?
-That's correct.
This one, I think
you're gonna get,
but I love her and I love this.
Here's the quote.
-Yes. Well, I do know that
that is Ramona Singer.
-Yeah. There we go.
-I'm thinking you're making
a bigger mole --
No, not a bigger mole.
-Mountain out of a mole hill?
-Yeah, you're making a mountain
out of a hole mill.
[ Ding ]
-Hole mill.
-Mountain out of a hole mill.
-Yes.
-All right, ready?
-Yeah.
-The last quote is...
[ Laughter ]
-One of the all-time greats
from "The Real Housewives
of Atlanta,"
Shereé Whitfield.
-That is correct!
Let's take a look.
You did it!
-I felt the need to
tug on her wig.
I did not try to pull it off.
I did not want to pull it off.
I just wanted to shift it
a little bit.
[ Ding, ding, ding ]
-And shift it she did.
-The champ!
-Undisputed champion,
Andy Cohen, everybody!
His show, "Watch What
Happens Live," is on Bravo.